la télévision reste le média le plus
puissant en france avec pas moins de 41
3 millions de téléspectateurs chaque
jour une puissance qui brasse des
millions d'euros grâce à la publicité de
fait les stars du petit écran sont
rémunérés en conséquence les salaires de
certains animateurs peuvent atteindre
des sommes vertigineuses jean pierre
pernaut qui vient d'annoncer son départ
du jt de tf1 annonce il ya quelques mois
tout schéma moins de 2000 euros par
journal soit 50000 euros mensuels très
très heureux nagui quant à lui gagnerait
1 million d'euros par an et en cumulé
sur l'ensemble de ses émissions sur
france 2 et 120000 euros pour
l'animation de son émission sur france
inter ça marche
karine ferri serez payé 1500 euros pour
chaque tirage du loto quant à cyril
féraud son salaire s'élèverait à 650
euros par jour pour l'animation de slam
surprend froid en bas je trouve ça
génial
alors selon vous les stars de la télé
sont elles trop payés par actif bien sûr
l'espoir qui voit là les politiques et
les stars de télé jordan de l'ugtg qui a
une émission sur notre top people à qui
il se bat avec qui j'ai ce passe des
choses folles et tout le monde lui dit
si con mais combien il gagne alors oui
ou non vous avez au pied de pancartes si
vous pouviez si vous pouvez participer
alors jordan toit pour toi est ce
qu'elles sont trop payés parce que toi
tu connais les types de tous alors dit
nous un peu plus je les connais les
chiffres et franchement oui je pense que
les personnalités de télé sont trop
payés
maintenant après c'est très particulier
parce que ça dépend qui et qui fait quoi
et c'est aussi en fonction souvent de la
notoriété de la personne n'assure donc
ça dépend plan ne plein plein plein de
choses en fait alors est ce qu on a vu
des on a vu des chiffres passés mine de
rien pour vous gilbert dc oui encore
bien sûr c'est que je par rapport aux
politiques par rapport aux sportifs
c'est oui pareillement c'est trop parce
que même moi je vais honnêtement je
considère que ce sont des gars des
revenus trop important la télé c'est
chaque français à sa télé où on se
regarde dans la télé et je trouve que
les gens qui sont regardés dans la télé
devrait pareillement donner l'exemple
comme les politiques il donnera moins
payé et je trouve un suçon des salaires
baissent ou mai mais ses termes de
rendement la vie je vous le donnerai
salaires qui me choque nommé tout allait
révéler pensée dont il s'agit est ce
qu'on parle d'un animateur qui n'est
qu'à nîmes
mais naïve là on va pas rentrer et on
[Musique]
dit que vous êtes trop payés bien mais à
ce moment là chez vrai nom les rangs de
l'aja les babines au rendez-vous de
production et vous réalisez 6ème et
investissez de l'argent vous payez des
impôts oui donc c'est oui parce que vous
faites
n'essayez pas de me défendre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
paré services publics et le service
privé alors une boîte privée décide de
payer alors une vedette à laquelle
rapporte der des chercheurs budgétaires
et des recettes publicitaires
voilà c'est autre chose sur fond de
télévision alors mais benjamin castaldi
roland n'est pas physique qui commence
devant ça me va venir sur loire de quoi
sur le négoce et l'hypocrisie de tous
alors moi j'ai essayé de plus parler
d'argent parce que ça m'a coûté très
cher vous ne parlez jamais d'argent qui
avait jamais on en parlait encore dit
non pas pour vous on suppute on suppute
ont pu arrêter tu pied des sénateurs qui
se sont éclatés dirhams
mais moi je touche 6000 euros par mois
10 mo par mois ils nous prennent pour
des jambons ouais les chambres à la
nsbih mots des gens nous ont fumé même
te fais la morale sur l'écologie est
loin le temps où il faut se comporter
comme il faut dépenser son blé le mec il
prend je veux dire d'accord et moi on
est on est dans la même dynamique
je croyais peut aider mes narines
il m'a dit qu'on va y prenez un où elle
a dit je prends un million d'euros par
mois il est tombé oui mais je pense que
ça rend plus mois par an il ya donc son
année alors que je vous le dis en school
et je vous dis la vérité je connais
alain sudi qu'il a donnée bushiste nagui
un million d'euros par an avait écouté
mais bon chez nous en france inter et
ils gagnent 12000 euros par mois en tout
cas donné les bouchées doubles mais par
moi ou pour brouiller l'image est tout
content le groupe et je vous promets que
nagui c'est le bushido côté badel très
bien c'est magnifique
non mais je vous jure que non mais j'ai
des chiffres mais au lycée c'est le mont
sinaï que la boîte de production et ont
bien sûr tout compris et la vente non
oui on préfère les yeux c'est bon cyril
lassé d'être démago c'est d'être choquée
s'est dit de dire comment c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une période de crise donc
dès qu'on parle d'argent
sapphire les oui monsieur là j'ai
commencé qui fait il fait rêver les gens
vous fait rêver les gens aux cheveux
gris moi mais c'est ma base on vous nous
faites et bien sûr que si moi je vais
dans la relance mais aussi et peut-être
mais je veux dire pas falloir arrêter
cette démagogie c'est absolument
insupportable
franchement c'est tellement facile de
dire ah ouais mais ceux qui gagnent tous
les week-ends et ben oui mais ils font
des choses qu'ils emploient des gens et
ils font rêver les gens francesca ça
peut choquer bien sûr je joue quand même
ferry qui voici le tirage du mercredi 7
ans elle le regarda un moule tomberg et
2006 nous et on remet tout en cause
aussi à des poules
donné alors là oui mais en fait vous
remettez vous en cause en fait ça va
alors attendez alors je suis vraiment
séparé que les footballeurs c'est
évidemment que c'est trop payé pour ce
qu'on fait et là vous allez me tomber
dessus sahraouis étiez etc etc
c'est beaucoup trop payé pour ce qu'on
fait après on donne du bonheur aux gens
on crée de l'emploi et evs et
effectivement c'est possible pour moi
c'est trop payé une vraie sacré de l'amp
mais je ne comprends pas je crois en moi
je donne pas de bonnard yonne fait
longtemps que j'ai pas des deux bonnes
heures à comprends pas pourquoi tu mets
oui pour les stars de la télé tue mais
non pour les politiques passent les
policiers à cheval quel est ton argent s
est ton argent et politique bien sûr
mais là c'est pas mon argent c'est son
argent a le même service public venu son
argent alors quand est maire d'un
village et oui 500 euros à user du chant
taper le ballon du bras alors c'est vrai
que la responsabilité des maires elle
est beaucoup plus habilité dans la
d'animateur moi j'ai jamais cru dire
merde de 500 balles par mois dans une
petite population avec en plus ils
travaillent à côté je suis on l'appelle
il obligé de quitter son travail parce
que si tu le savais les merkel et dans
les petites communes maires je te
rappelle pas si si si tu savais il
travaille à côté
donc moi je ne peux pas être choqué je
dis qu'on est trop payé à rien [ __ ] ça
c'est vrai enfin c'est vrai je suis
choqué et je suis choqué par les 1
million que je viens d'entendre de nagui
parce que ça c'est mes impôts voilà
c'est on tourne en rond ce que c'est
mais attention c'est messi sur les rapa
kelly qui ont voulu réagir souviens je
voulais juste nager race qui disait il
ya une différence entre les maires des
villages dont je suis par les
nourrissons h 24 en train de travailler
donc ciblé que tu veux et une différence
avec les médecines dorment au sénat
quand même donné on peut pas tout
comparer donc dans chaque catégorie
yahia d'eyadema des caresses les boules
devant la télé
ça suffit jordan de luxe c'est drôle
parce que vous vous énervez tout c'est
vrai que ça tant l'argent j'ai remarqué
ça hallucinant s'attendent pas
s'attendre alors il ya plein de chiffres
assez hallucinant qu'on a découvert
notamment sur l'émission donc l'instant
de luxe que je présente sur notre stop
people révèle très bonne chère vous avez
vu vous avez bien j'ai regardé les fans
par contumace à beaucoup je peux vous
sortir mais eric brunet a été débauché
un garçon qui lui arrive sur lci que
j'aime beaucoup c'est tranquille ici et
maintenant qui a été une évolution chez
nous il est allé sur lci il a été
débauché de lci pour de rmc pardon rmc
de la débauche et 60 36 mille euros par
don donc il a été débauché 36000 euros
est l'une des trente six mille euros
pour qu'il soit débauché à matin et des
transferts donne exactement
ils lui ont donné de l'argent ouais
alors qu'il fait soixante mille
téléspectateurs ce qui est comme je vous
le rappelle quatre fois moins que
l'émission de jean marc morandini sur
6000 et non-stop people à la wii s'est
trompé il mais bernard montiel maritale
et débauché pour trois quarts en bas
rien
je tiens tout à l'heure j'étais en loge
et je parlais avec lionel stan lee le
directeur général et je lui disais mais
alors lionel est ce qu il ya un salaire
qu'on peut donner une feuille oui tu
peux donner celui de bernard montiel
puisque lui viendrait pour 1,40 barjou
sûr qu'il tisse aussi
l'organisateur télé
trop payés par rapport au wifi très haut
et au sort qui vous veulent tous les
chiffres ce soir bernard montiel vous
dit non ils sont potes et son patron
payer les gens de télé mais non c'est ce
qu'on rapporte de toute façon c'est un
système qui est comme ça je veux dire on
travaille depuis des années moi ça fait
35 ans que sur les télévisions et à
rapporter quoi en 35 ans
l'avion
la plus importante que l'on puisse
donner un spectateur le bonheur le dis
car ça on prétend assurer qu'on a besoin
de vous bernard montiel alors mais
j'aimerais comprendre il reste moi
j'aimerais vous plaît je regarde tous et
où je vous écoute et sculpté au blind
test ya un truc comme je vais vous dire
s'il je vous ai tous invités un par un
sur mon émission et cyril se débine tous
savent qu'ils ont perdu la vie de ta
mère tu m'as vidéo c'est pas ton
portable du bonbon et tu me fais des
trucs je vous est-ce qu'on est trop payé
6 mai oui genre bah oui c'est une grosse
bêtise tu as dit et ça fait que tant de
téléspectateurs même c'est que t'as vu
que les gens étaient payés en fonction
du nombre de téléspectateurs regardaient
comme dire que dans ce genre salaires
montré des cendres est comme ça une
jauge qui montrait des cendres est tout
le temps mais c'est comme ça que vous
êtes pays en général les animateurs
salaires en fonction de la notoriété est
ce que vous êtes
est-ce que c'est trop payé s'il vous
plaît il ya pas de l'oie castaldi qui
est très vénère ce soir moi je vous dire
c'est vrai qu'on m'a souvent demandé de
donner mon salaire donné j'ai jamais
donné parce que déjà je trouve ça
indécent et c'est vrai que moi pour moi
je trouve qu'on est trop payé par
rapport à ce qu'on fait je dis je dis la
vérité je dis la vérité conclut l'unique
vous avez pu vous avez plus de missions
communes et garder et honte mais je vais
voir
zisis communiqué sont sur l'arène vous
gagnez dit la vérité et prenez pas les
gens pour des cons que c'est toi que je
dis voilà après effectivement de
l'argent ils en ont marre de tf1 j'étais
extrêmement bien payé vous étiez pays a
été enfin dit la vérité mais une fortune
c'est pour ça que sauf que dès qu'on
vient battre demain c'est quoi ces 1 me
pour l'année j'avais gagné plus d'un
million de rosaires gagné plus d'un
milliards dé beir bien sûr combien ça
pouvait varier entre 1 min 3 millions 3
millions ça dure et très peu de temps
mais oui maintenant alors à un accord se
dessine crête est un contre sens plus
les clubs plus qu'un million cinq cent
mille euros par an pendant combien
d'années quatre cinq ans dans deux trois
en même pas trois ans à trois ans mais
par contre on tue les 50% je pense qu'il
est très normal mais oui j'ai gagné
beaucoup d'argent et benjamin pour cette
fameuse publicité faux nom a révélé je
ne répondrai pas la guerre mais c'est
quoi entre un milieu qui l'ont jamais la
bible
dis moi ce qui me gêne un petit peu dans
la discussion là c'est qu'on voulait
c'est en tant que vous battez votre
coulpe en 100 ans ou pas sous prétexte
qu'on fait du divertissement
on ne mérite pas de salaire pardon mais
vous tous qui êtes là vous bossez
vachement pour être là pourquoi pas un
horizon non non non
[Rires]
travailler pour des émissions produites
par ses bras gauche vous étiez et on
mérite ce qu'on gagne
après on dit bienvenue des gens benjamin
gagner beaucoup d'argent enfin rappelez
vous ce que c'était que love story non
merci c'est énoncer regardé par démonter
il a fait les plus gros efforts tendent
à riki nakaya beaux-arts l'étranger est
passée téléspectateurs regardent et
merci oui à 98% l'alabama qui a voté à
non